and why did you take her out
no dude we left because i think if i
even approach this girl somebody's gonna
think oh this guy's trying to be a
pervert yeah or get some meth yeah i
think you're a seller yeah or seller
you're a math dealer
yeah so anyway i think meth is uh
there's some hotties out there
back off my broccolini
get your life together
touch me bro i'm not touching you dude
you got to know yourself man
dude you should draw yourself and then
look at it or something because i feel
like you don't know yourself that good
yeah if you think you yeah well i'm just
saying it felt different taking it with
him and standing next to you all right
dude
bro no dude you don't understand no he
got he took it it didn't [ __ ] feel
like it was
bro go to an 11 go to a 11 and 12 year
old basketball game nice look at the
point guard i love
that shoot
i love when sentences start and you
don't know where they're at
even though you're talking
that's kind of my move too though i just
start talking and we'll see where it is
what is it today brendan's in in a
cul-de-sac brenda's in right back where
they started
i don't know i like this i like this i
know which i had i wish i had a good
friend that gave me one well no nick
[ __ ]
said here and i said okay have any more
size than that nick
uh i mean i just grabbed it out of the
studio
[Laughter]
[ __ ] like that yeah huh a little dicky
little and taft yeah a little dicky taft
stole your [ __ ]
i've had people trying to steal think
boy they tried thick boy running club
but they do thick with four c's
seriously if it ain't three you ain't
[ __ ] wait but so but they can get away
with it right because i i copyright and
own three c's but they'll do two c's
four c's [ __ ] though if you got the
[ __ ] four c's you're or two c's it's
like it's like it's wearing even if you
spell thick correctly you're kind of a
[ __ ]
you should open up about four seasons
and it's just fat people at a hotel
oh the plus size thing yeah
look at this [ __ ] that's hilarious bro
that's obviously nick dude
it's clearly nick and chen's [ __ ]
business here
it looks like a lumberjack for only fans
dude that's what it looks like look at
the guy's beard dude that's fake it's
nick with my body and then they [ __ ]
put in thick with two c's
heavy mustache wow a lot of hairs per
capita yeah that looks like that looks
like when somebody is on the meds when
they're it's a woman transferring over
yeah yeah that looks like the guy's
gonna call in to do king in the sting
but
though but this is [ __ ] uh he's got
that's that's the times square of hair
under there that is unbelievable yeah
do people steal your [ __ ]
your merch is dope the life rips
yeah
yeah those companies out there that do
live reps yeah oh yeah but well i don't
care [ __ ] whatever
but fans don't show up to the show like
with a king scene shirt like dude i love
the merch like that's not awesome really
yeah i'm like all the time
that's not our [ __ ] like really i'm like
no bro how am i and rye frips matt rife
did that rife rip shirt that was kind of
diddy yeah that's dicey that was great
actually yeah that's hilarious i gotta
look at that i don't care about that
[ __ ] whatever i like matt you know no oh
yeah i like man i just i that was kind
of like that's like i never saw that it
feels it felt a little blatant it's like
when jeremiah and stevie did good
friends
oh you have a problem with it yeah
apparently santino did yeah yeah yeah
santino did he find it
remember santino i think try to maybe
take him to court or do something
not crazy i think he hired a heavy
yeah yeah i think he's gonna kill him
but hold on though but hold on stevie
weeby
yeah that bobby is his brother that's
why it makes sense i forgot about that
and i was like that's kind of weird they
did bad friends and then i thought oh
wait though that's actually his brother
so who gives a [ __ ] yeah you know is
like yeah exactly
his brother now yeah they didn't want to
help him out they didn't want to do
nothing and that kid's bottle fed still
dude
bro oh if he ain't getting people and
only fans to come bottle feed him i
don't know who is that guy who stevie oh
stevie yeah stevie stevie with the beast
yeah
i like stevie wonder like stevie yeah
the whole thing is definitely it's like
hanging out at a preschool being around
him i feel like a little bit like a
chinese preschool yeah it's dangerous i
would not be shocked if he sleeps in a
baby crib you know what i'm talking
about
come on chin
how tall is stevie oh i met him once
he's too nice yeah right he's just
like two nice too short fourth grade
tall yeah and he's 50 what 56. i know he
is crazy bobby's 50. see they started
with good friends and then santino
kobashed it
oh and now they're called scissor bros
oh did they just switch the name ah well
i mean they're yeah but they it's not
even that they're ripping it off they're
making a joke of it which means you made
it right
right that's a good point if you're like
hey look we're we're joking yeah it's
flattering whenever he copies my [ __ ]
it's flat all right it's not like it
takes away from my business yeah yeah i
mean what taf is doing is taking away
but no
i hate to keep harping on that but yeah
still after him well that's a little let
me go after i emailed the guy and he
said oh we're friends we're big friends
of brennan shaw big big fans
because who says big friends but all
your fans are personal friends yeah i've
seen them like your show
they come in there bro they want to
laugh they look like you i i mean i
opened for chris and i i was
flabbergasted i just
freaked out there's too many [ __ ]
chicks in the crowd was it really this
is not my demo yeah cause you know what
i you know you know it's not like
yeah this is not what i do his demo is a
lot of extras from those like uh
those suit commercials
you know
it's a lot of guys i feel like they
didn't get cast in there yeah whenever i
opened for either of you chris is all
women yours i look in the crowd they're
all
right wait your demo
was sad
i know it was great right there was
crying that's a good that's a dude
that's a lot of people man hey what i'm
saying
yeah yeah
yeah dude i don't know who my dad i can
never really figure it out i know your
demo is great man you're doing that
you're saying that no as long as they
come out yeah [ __ ] it i don't give a
[ __ ] your demo is a blend of mine and
chris's yeah you don't know that brendan
yeah i've seen your shows i'll see them
tonight at the comedy store it's it's a
blend of us
i don't know it sounds like you're just
making you're just saying something out
loud and that's coming from the guy who
starts a sentence and doesn't know where
it's gonna go
[ __ ] you guys how about that dude
start this show bro
[ __ ] you guys hey
here's my thing [ __ ] you where have you
been
plural we got a king over there we got a
king there
the one constant is the stain
am i right nick
yeah he didn't really say yeah he just
laughed
and said yeah he said yeah he said yeah
he said yeah the old soft constant they
call it yeah that's what they call them
brother damn what's going on here this
is somebody this looks like a mix
between you and dalia right this is a
hundred percent of brendan's shop fan
yeah this guy this guy looks like a
dirty mustache he's got the opposite of
the hitler mustache he's got he's got no
hair where hitler had the hair yeah he's
got the spitler i feel like
he's just going to be saving the the
hair under his lip looks like it should
[ __ ] be on the top of the goddamn
that's reversed how does this guy
[ __ ] do this guy what's up with this
dude what's he going to do
derek franco from san jose sorry theo
you probably thought this was a
different kind of red hat my bad bro i
got a nice little debate club for you
guys though a foot race between brendan
and theo
we saw the foot race between brendan and
chappelle
but we got two
white boys ready to race
theo first brendan
foot race who wins
better yet a decathlon
physical
and with the academics
the two plus two equals i'm the only one
with a degree in here can theo
show up to the race fair point obviously
this guy's talking to brandon can you
understand what's going on
i'll tell you this first of all chris
chris runs like a [ __ ] ostrich
everybody
even though you don't say it people know
that dude i'm a bad runner but but i do
crazy jumps and good jumps when i'm
doing jumps bro i got a box at home i
jump on the box i jump off the box my
cardio gets up it's phenomenal i mean
say what you want about the running i
get it
i live on a hill and i [ __ ] practice
but with the box josh forget it
dude i'm just saying over the whole box
you run like an endangered species
i do 100
you know what i run like the last one i
run like the last one in the species
that's what i wrote
oh no wonder they died out
no wonder there's only him left yeah
it's awful i saw myself running on video
and bro i made my girl take i met
kristen take it and i was like send that
to me i want to send it to the guys i
saw it and let me just tell you i did
not send it to the guy it was bad
i got to take longer strides
oh you do short strides huh yeah i don't
know you know what it is i'm tall i'm a
tawdrick of what i'm six too but a lot
of it is torso man yeah
that sucks frankly you're like a t-rex
yeah small legs real big yeah but i'm
broad right because you see my shoulders
if most people just talk to you like
this and they don't really look down
i feel like you're taller than me you're
up you're taller than six too but bro
you always want me to be bigger we're
the same thing you have a sound
but only mentally i'm not the [ __ ]
physical i mean no way bro
dude yeah you i don't think you would do
the wrong you wouldn't win i would think
i would beat you in a race you would
beat me right now i i don't have
hamburgers well right now you'd mind
good you came back now because you know
that you would beat him in a race now
there you go i did see the video this
[ __ ] looks kind of definitely hectic
yeah
it looks like you ate the ham out of
your
bro that's what it looks like but wait
you are do you run do you run yes you do
i wrong i don't say it like i should
know act like you're a marathon i mean
he would be ordering an uber at a
marathon dude you guys both neither one
of you guys can run i'm not why i'm
i'll give theo this he is way more
athletic than people give him like he
shot a takedown on me and i was like oh
can i buy that pull up that video of me
on that trail head again if you really
need to if you want to see some
athleticism i was walking down the mud
yeah yeah that was
but what about like you you push weights
around what do you do for workout your
workout you ever seen
last night i know you got a dumper yeah
i used to dunk i used to dunk so yeah i
buy that with the [ __ ] ass on you oh
yeah yeah forget it you put a drink down
on that oh i got that uh what is that
amistad ass
yeah you belong in a [ __ ] under it yeah
for real here can we get out that's you
first look what he's wearing huh that's
you bro yeah you're in way better shape
now i'm sorry it's not starting good is
that ron white
is that ron white
unreal dude
brendan goes hey we're gonna go to
church later if you want to come over
here so are you dressed like that for
church yes
shoes
where is this by the way right behind my
house
i asked you is it a hike you got all the
business
it's not
this is hilarious bro it's shitty you
put him in this situation as a friend
thank you
yeah and the cat if it's a decathlete if
it has academia in it
you're getting stomped out well you
thought academia was uh it was a nut and
a dish
and i destroyed jesus what are you
talking about who could name the most
cheeses and i ran so i got cheddar and
that's it bro cheddar
american hold on cheddar american
munster uh swiss
that's it for me man we got that sweet
red
sweet red cheese sweet red cheddar he
starts doing brands
daddy gets detailed i know it's a sweet
red from england you don't get detailed
you forgot about blue cheeseburger look
at that
wagon right there that pull up that's
your ass right there that's it you like
when i got in shoulders you got in the
back door first oh yeah dude i got you
got in the back door that's cool i'm
jealous yeah i am i'm a little jealous
yeah i am too i the only time it's tough
having a nice ass is when you want to
lay down on your back somewhere flat
and you can't but it feels like water's
going i feel like water's going up your
nose yeah
that's not good
and also everybody thinks you're a
pervert because you're
you're thrusting your hair
is he trying to [ __ ] the ceiling yeah
what's going on like oh look at this
you're trying to [ __ ] the sun at the
beach and you're just laying there dude
let's take a break from the kings and
the sting i'm talking about crystalia
and theovonk cause guess what the moment
we've been waiting for the super bowl is
here kids that's right and draftking
sportsbook the official sports brand
partner the super ball 56 is giving new
customers 56-1 odds on either team the
bengals or the rams bet just five
dollars and get 280 in free bets if your
team wins draftkings sportsbook is now
live in new york meaning you can bet
from almost a third of the country
that's right they're live in nyc baby
congrats draftkings if sportsbook isn't
in your state yet play draftkings daily
fantasy football contest for super bowl
56
new customers can get a free shot at one
million dollar top prizes with the first
deposit download the draftking
sportsbook app and use promo code kats
and get 56-1 odds on either team bet
just five dollars and get 280 in free
bets if your team wins that's promo code
kats at draftking sportsbook the
official sports betting partner of the
super ball 56 21 plus minimum age and
location requirements vary by
jurisdiction c
sportsbook for full list of requirements
state specifics responsible gambling
resources voidware prohibited gambling
problem call 100 gambler in tennessee
call or text the tennessee red line
1-800-889
in connecticut call
888-789-7777 or visit
ccpg.org chat in new york call
8778 hopny or text h-o-p-e-n
four six seven three six nine if you're
still listing download your african
sports app use the promo code cats hello
fresh hello friends that's right man
listen we're all busy out there you got
kids you got work you got school you got
classes you binge watching your favorite
show you don't got time to get all the
ingredients and make all your own meals
that's where hellofresh helps you out
man
hellofresh delivers pre-portioned
ingredients to your door including farm
fresh produce that arrives within a week
so you get convenience without skimping
on quality skip the trip to the grocery
store forget about it man those long
lines wasting money we don't need any of
that hellofresh helps you out hellofresh
has a fit and wholesome recipes to
satisfy whatever diet you're on your
boys on carnivore listen if you're low
calorie low carb carb conscious we got
you covered with hellofresh man all
right hellofresh offers 50 menu and
market items to choose from every
freaking week including veggie fit and
wholesome family friendly gourmet
options my kiddos eat this up man go to
hellofresh.com
king16 use the code king16 for up to 16
free meals and three free gifts all
right that is
hellofresh.com
king16 all right hello fresh america's
number one meal kid so decathlete i
don't know i think i don't know what all
the sports are but if it's like squid
game is this squid games between chris
theo and i squid games of you'd lose not
a chance you'd well the the the part
you'd kill at in squid games is the last
part you wouldn't even get there first
of all the tug of war who's beat me and
tug away okay fine i understand but also
but it's at heights but remember who won
the tug of war the guy who really knew
how to play tug of war yeah but he saw
the technique and i'm assuming okay so
now you're saying now after squid games
you might win yeah all right well it's
cheating
yeah well
i don't know um
fair enough
i like the honesty though
look by the way this guy had to dress up
in his police uniform just so he wasn't
wearing carhartt you know that right
he's like that's all i got so i might as
well do it on the job this dude looks
like the eighth uh dwarf essay
what's up king in this thing whoa
you know how boss it was to hold it and
then when it plays he goes like this and
it's like jesus christ this is like an
awkward digiorgio commercial
he looks like an emoji that's a metal
gear isn't it let me tell you right now
you're solid
this dude's an nft 100
what's up king in the sting yup this is
nate
out and he's from washington
i got a debate clay for you guys would
you rather fight
with a
messed out paranoid
female
or
with a drunk
uh violent guy
who
tells you he doesn't care what happens
i've done both of those things
just a little insight
the size of the met that woman does not
matter she could be the tiniest chick
i'll tell you right now
when meth is in your system
superhuman strength all right if you
guys love the show
gang gang buzz buzz honestly dude if
you're if she's really tiny it's
impossible to fight her because she's
just like yeah
[Music]
um but i don't know i i i have my
opinion but i'd like to hear yours first
brendan especially brendan
yeah yeah yeah
he's a [ __ ] idea because he's a [ __ ]
i'm i'm going drunk guy i'm going drunk
guy all day okay the drunk guy doesn't
have you know the wits about them you
know distance
no matter how big they are if they're
hammered you're gonna run circles around
them a messed up chick
that superhuman human strength just
titties all up on your back
i mean no titties yeah the titties are
the first to wear out yeah with meth
yeah you've seen it you've seen a person
like you know those before and after
pictures this is a month on meth i've
seen a neighbor on math a what a
neighbor yeah really yeah i've seen way
more than just yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah but you see them every day i'm
saying you know what i mean if you have
a picture back and forth before and
after yeah yeah they look they look it's
yeah they're they're all shredded
they're all shredded they look like beef
jerky but they're all shredded but thin
but yeah but i say drunk guy dude meet
me at 240 son you know what i'm saying
bruh bring both those [ __ ] one in
each hand dude i'll take that guy down
meth people you gotta tie him up that's
the number one thing
meth bring rope don't don't fight a meth
person you're gonna lose they'll do dirt
peep there's there's things where people
met people will take the zipper out of
their own coat and beat you with it yeah
also they're they're they're they're
trapped their cardio is insane too
they're also yeah they don't stop
they don't stop drunk guy he's slow yeah
you move out the way a little bit you're
laughing you put him to sleep it's not
even like you heard him you just like
pamplona yeah yeah yeah so you just yeah
yeah a drunk guy all day 100 math
a whole all day insane how about this
guy on meth no way forget it oh like a
big guy in math oh [ __ ] you're dead yeah
maybe harry carry on yourself being up
everybody you die anyway yeah a woman on
meth i think is gonna be a real
and some of them are kind of hot bruh
bro early the first dude i saw a woman
on meth the other day at starbucks dude
and it broke she was she was working and
she was actually good behind the wheel
beautiful outside of the starbucks and
at first i well was there meeting my
friend and she kind of looked over
and i was like oh this lady likes me
and uh so i'm like on the moon you know
i'm out there on the moon i'm putting
american flag i'm right theo on it you
know what i'm saying i'm feeling excited
for myself
and then
i start realizing something's not right
with her and i mean stunning like kind
of like coffee though uh-huh are we sure
it's math oh it's magical it's not a lot
of maybe espresso shots so then what
happened coffee and she's sitting there
just trying to tie her just like
just braiding her own legs entire
sandals she's trying to tighten
then i start realizing she's losing and
i was like oh my god because then it's
like what happens to this girl
somebody's gonna take advantage of her
or somebody's gonna lie did you take her
out no dude we left because i think if i
even approach this girl somebody's going
to think oh this guy's trying to be a
pervert yeah or get some meth yeah i
think you're a seller yeah or seller
you're the math dealer
yeah so anyway i think meth is uh
there's some hotties out there
[Laughter]
in l.a the [ __ ] there's hot homeless
people not even just chicks
and you're like did you just get
homeless but then you're like he's too
dirty to have just got homeless right
but also um
they'll walk it like i was at the coffee
bean yesterday you know how you know
yeah they're allowed what's your thing
yeah and uh a guy walked in
screaming the n-word just screaming it
black guy punching himself in the white
guy yeah so it was a white guy doing it
yeah yeah
and punching his own face over and over
again well that's for saying the inward
hard he was punishing himself yeah
but
but at least you know but it was like uh
and [ __ ]
you know you want to like i saw somebody
there also that was like bro they were
like don't be all like racist oh and
it's like oh no but this goes beyond
that he's not racist he's just out to
lunch yeah
yeah that's the last
damn yeah
i don't know if i could
i wonder what my man was me that's how
it ends that's how the story ends yeah
what my last word would be if i got all
sick that you know sick and you got one
word left in the tank what do you think
yours would be
and his with this dudes was just the
worst one he kind of trumped us yeah
that's tough i think i'd probably say
trump 2024 oh yeah
people don't know if i'm right or left
bro
that's how it's going to stay man but
they'll push her if dude though i know i
know
i don't want to all right we met far
right chris
chris the wolf he's trying to push
he starts watching fox or cnn far right
i know dude i try to [ __ ]
damn it they won't get you you know
we'll get to
put on a [ __ ] don't say this don't
say that
they should have like a woke superhero
wonder what that would be like oh
[ __ ] uh yeah just uh it's a trans
captain planet short hair yeah with
chick with the short hair that looks
like the scooby doo girl
yeah
it's called captain marvel
yeah oh
who's that oh yeah she would be it she
would be it 100 if they made a movie
about what or megan reppino who's that
soccer lady
oh yeah oh yeah you took the knee yep
yeah yep that's her power that's her
finishing move she just takes a knee
there boom sonic [ __ ]
red hat's just flying everywhere
pronouns are her he yeah
yeah they just hit you with a pronoun
yeah bam
them them they there's is
wow she's even look at that picture
she's literally that's that body
language is equality do you know what i
mean that picture drives me not that
whole body it's just that
nuts
it's all good she's good she's a good
person right well they got now they got
the woman that's with the man uh
genitals or whatever swimming in the
water too
wait oh you got the you got the the
oh oh uh the jeopardy champ too trans
wow see that's
dominating but that's a trans thing
that's okay that's fine yeah ufc is a
little different yeah brain trans is
you're talking about homeboy that jumped
in the pool put on a dress jump the pool
started beating all the girls asses
though not leah thomas a little bit a
little bit easier to do that as a man
i just wonder how yeah i don't know if
you feel like it's
i can't do competition and the the head
person ncaa swim team uh like stepped
down was like i won't partake so that
was him and now he's her right yeah okay
got it and dominating yeah of course did
he switch to get the championship yeah
because he wasn't [ __ ] as a male 1 came
in place
and they should average out the two yep
pick a lane oh right like that's your
record yeah yeah right got it you did
good and bad yeah man yeah
damn or they should
oh wow oh that's a jeopardy yeah she's
dominating yeah bro smart [ __ ] kill
it
daily double
yeah is the daily no crushing yeah
dang bro yeah i don't know maybe in the
future though everybody's going to be
trans
yeah you wish could be
i kind of hope so [ __ ] it everybody
brendan look what's happening brendan
i we're talking about two trans people
right now winning competition right
right right i think honestly i i i
everyone should be the same
all the same whatever it is whatever it
is just right well we're all evening out
like the race thing's a problem now
everyone's going to be beige oh i think
that's just how it's going to be right
i've been there everyone would be a
little asian i mean everyone's going to
[ __ ] we're going to [ __ ] i don't know
how long it's going to take but pretty
soon we won't be alive
no we won't be alive yeah it might be
sooner than you think four decades we'll
see it out of our windows when we're
older
we could
depending on where you live right i'm
not in the south i'm dying but you think
people will still yell look at these
beige and you know people still probably
throw the inwards for sure yeah yeah
yeah yeah your spring would be in the
window yeah [ __ ] them
are they am i right
with a huge ass
and three mullets look at these beigers
they're the same color as us but we know
where they really are
we know where they come from
they're only because then it would be oh
you're only a two
generation
oh come on you didn't follow him
all right i'm following that's your f
that'd be amazing no that's your son oh
good and then he's like oh you're only
two generations beige that's what it's
going to be yeah right oh you're only
second generation right right right
right and then hit them with a slur
[Laughter]
but is it going to be as much fun if
there isn't because a little bit of
racism is it's not racism but a little
well a light racism is pretty funny no
listen if you're playing tekken or if
you're playing street fighter 2 and you
just want to [ __ ] okay look i'm
playing the
dollism's beating me i want to be
i i want to in the comfort of my own
home be shitty to indians right right
because of and he's winning right and
you can't get around his long arm
shooting at you right or the [ __ ]
fiery's breathing fair enough right okay
but if you take that outside and then go
to starbucks and you see an indian and
you've got your dallas and [ __ ] going on
and this [ __ ] long-armed
[ __ ] indian and this is what
you do at starbucks that's a problem
that's bad
we can't do that in your own home yeah
cool they can when you heat this scone
like heat it with your breath you know
yeah exactly 100 yeah oh why you have so
much clothes on you know you can't be
doing that but if you're also group text
trusted people fair enough yeah you
leaked some group text merlot we've all
had crazy group tags right you only get
campaigns yeah but it's like you know
you just [ __ ] you you know comfort of
your own it's like i want somebody to be
exposed because of a text and then have
it be like bro that [ __ ] was for my
friend [ __ ] you you know what i mean
circle of trust yeah exactly
so
how much so some racism is okay you
think a little bit in the privacy or
your own home right yeah yes or with
friends that you trust and love yeah
like you're losing to e honda and he
keeps doing that 100 i'll be mean to
chin all of a sudden he can't just mean
to chance for no reason or obviously he
has nothing to do with it yeah
is he korean he's got to be no it's
japanese no it's not a korean flag isn't
it no no no no no because there's a sumo
wrestler all right wrestler
japanese yeah
and this whole thing is that brendan is
completely racist but yeah yeah yeah
he just did no i don't know
equality equality yeah that's japanese
well you know what he's not from
anywhere because he's not about that
that's what he's japanese i mean
they gave him a japanese one yeah all
right let's get into something here
there's a guy right here still have his
tree up so drugs
yo what's up brandon theo eric stevie
weavey
bait club for you today here are those
guys
remedies you know what's the craziest
home remedy you've ever heard of or that
you know that actually works so recently
someone asked me if i've ever heard
about putting urine in kids ears when
they had a hearing
i told them i don't know nothing about
that but
uh
the note you guys got
that's a pedophile direct in the ears or
in a cup and then in the either way
either way it's [ __ ] weird just don't
put it out no don't put anything in your
ears unless a doctor says wow there's
that but then also if you get with a
latino like my girl my kids would be
sick she'll be like oh we gotta we gotta
rub uh vapor right yeah on their feet
and like that right right right your
feet can breathe and then like my throat
to be sore and she's like what we do is
we heat up a lime we put a lime in the
fire and they swallow the lime oh that
sounds like an old like it's like uh
american ingredients should do sage
around the house sage helps a lot of
stuff dude sage will keep the dark
spirits at bay and that's always been i
feel like a constant fair enough but
it's not really medical right yeah not
at all well but look at a lot of these
guys have you seen dope sick man those
people are medical and they're all high
on oxygen well that's michael keaton and
actors but yeah
well you know
but i'll say this dude if you're pouring
your your kid's going to be a freak when
he grows up if you're pouring
wee-wee yeah you're pissing me i can't
hear you all the piss
you got to talk past the piss you're
just like what
yeah if he's all pissed up dude if he's
all pissed he's at school his buddy
falls off the monkey bars and he starts
spraying on it yeah wait wait wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait-wait
get my ears get my ears yeah he's like
i'm a doctor
[Laughter]
i don't know uh yeah that sounds real
bad and also this guy knows a guy who
didn't know
turn them in yeah yeah it's pedophile
turn him in 100 pedophiles also that's
more than light racism right there dude
that's where i draw the line i'll tell
you this right now that was a white guy
who did that there's no way and if
that's a good that's a good that's good
artwork you did that
you
i didn't i don't think i did i did i do
that it's good that's uh what's it
called off my sentiment right yeah yeah
yeah
um what was i going to say about the
[ __ ] guy pissing kids you can't be
pissing yeah but um no uh
they're about to [ __ ] uh going skiing
tomorrow you look like it thanks you
decided to get dressed now
hot out done i don't like wearing new
stuff like the fur i don't like wearing
like like adventure stuff the day like
the same you want to break it in yeah i
just want to know what i'm gonna feel
like in it before i get up there aren't
you the guy aren't you hot right now
yeah i'm probably a little warmer i just
have to take this off and this is your
merch by the way and i love it so i'm
gonna keep that yeah i i am a little
warm but i'm excited who are you going
skiing ski or snowboard friends up in no
oregon oh damn you're going to oregon
yep you were saying you want to go and
but you don't know you want to go or you
know i do want to go now he wants to go
i know him i know i'm saying i don't
want to do stuff a lot of times until i
get there and i'm in it then i'm like
right now i'm okay so so but you feel
excited about this trip yeah oh so you
do want to go i get i struggle with that
[ __ ] all the time i don't even make
plans because i get nervous what if i
don't want to go yeah i mean oh that's
the worst that's all most of my life i
think a lot of people are like that now
yeah well especially with the [ __ ]
pandemic after that people realize what
they're what they could do at home yeah
you know
people started businesses yeah cults and
[ __ ] just at home you know you don't
have to go in the high grass anymore
like your point i'm fine once one time
i'll dread going there then once i'm
there i'm like i'm fine yeah once i'm
there yeah yeah
it's the anxiety
i don't want to i know and i was telling
theo earlier too about like it's the
having a kid helps a lot of that [ __ ]
yeah like
you have no choice well but but you but
you but i don't want to go to disneyland
but if calvin wants to go to disneyland
i want to go to disneyland correct
because i want to be there with him yeah
i don't want to get a monster jam over
the weekend of course the [ __ ] yeah
the warlocks they're making yeah some
more goats your network that's you
networking they're they're fans yeah
out there that's your fans dude that mix
business with pleasure yeah this episode
of kingston with crystalia theo vaughn
and my thick ass is brought to you by
better help that's right we're sponsored
by betterhelp if there's something
interfering with your happiness
preventing you from achieving your goals
what is it man get out of your way let
somebody help you let better help help
you out start communicating with a
professional therapist in under 48 hours
it's not a crisis line it's not
self-help it's professional therapy done
securely online
it's available worldwide login into your
account whenever you want man send a
message to your therapist and they'll
get right back to you man in a timely
manner all right it's more affordable
than traditional offline therapy and
financial aid is also available for you
guys out there all right listen man over
2 million people have taken charge of
their mental health and mental health is
finally a thing so don't be embarrassed
let better help help you out man all
right special offer for king and seeing
listeners get 10 10 off your first month
at
betterhelp.com kats that's
betterh-e-l-p-com cats um
but what were you saying before that you
were saying did you skip you were
talking about skiing i'm excited to go
oh you're getting the chair lift is the
most nerve-wracking for me when that
thing comes around it's just like god
what am i gonna do yeah it's almost like
being at your own wedding it's like am i
gonna do this or should i do this oh
yeah yeah and it surprises me how high
you get and there's no yeah no it's it's
not the right way to do it then what if
the wind picks up and they do this
[ __ ] cable break and it does yeah
people fall and you're trusting some
college kid on a [ __ ] internship that
and he checks
up on something
yeah they're vaping for dinner now two
people have like four hits off a vape
and then just go to sleep like damn that
guy just had dent it's like their diet
diets
peas is a vape flavor it's just like
it's getting real dicey man the um yeah
i i don't i don't ski i used to ski i
used to do snowboarding i used to
[ __ ] kill it you didn't do it
i did all that yeah i did all that
i did all that i did snowboarding dude
you know he didn't do it don't sit here
and agree with him everybody i'm not
saying
what am i gonna lie about skiing for i
don't know if he where'd you ski in new
jersey yes get in new jersey and it's a
lie and i also skied in utah
you didn't grow up skiing that's true
that's true in new jersey and i skied in
utah no maybe you wore a ski mask in new
jersey and got into some freaking crime
bro there's no ski there's no ice in new
jersey
i'm on this side bro i skied in new
jersey i skied in utah we're at at red
i'm trying to think about how young i
was when i did this [ __ ] i remember our
[ __ ] nanny took us but that was
probably in utah
are you rambling
we got rich bro not grown up whatever
you had a nanny for the game yeah after
we got rich [ __ ] you i got kidnapped two
times you idiot that's your fault bro
his nanny was looking around bro
you got you got [ __ ] kidnapped with a
dump truck like that bro you got [ __ ]
you got strength yeah but i didn't know
at the time nobody taught me anything oh
they were nice to you they tricked you
chris is privileged huh chris is
privileged you're rubbing your privilege
in our face i don't give a [ __ ]
oh yeah i forgot about it look at him
right there with his probably his nanny
right there having a good time
dude i wonder how old she is now
look at his freaking nanny
what's her name probably what was her
name peekaboo street
she looks she i look [ __ ] i look uh
lanky there i gotta i don't know man
you put on some size yeah you look like
a vape i don't like [ __ ] where you gotta
here's what i don't like here's what i
don't like
i don't like the stuff
where
you gotta
get all the gear yeah it's too much i
just if that's why stand up is my
favorite [ __ ] you just show up there's
no amps and [ __ ] you don't have to bring
a guitar
doing [ __ ] though yeah but but if i
gotta do it i'm just going to show up i
don't need to get the mask and the skis
and the [ __ ] you know plug and play i i
just i'm in dude i'm i'm already there i
don't agree with them
it's fine it's fine everybody's
different and i like that about you i
want you to [ __ ] like skiing if you
like skiing you don't go skiing that
much that's what i'm saying but ski when
i can
let's tell you a lot more you can see a
lot more than you ski now i did ski i
did sled recently
um i would like to ski more i'm going to
say that all right fair enough really
and i hope in the future that i do and
i'll wait i'm okay with wearing the
stuff the night before the day before i
like that but i like that i like that i
like that you break in your [ __ ] thank
you thank you i do personally like that
thank you yeah thank you and you
chill out man yeah chill the [ __ ] out
bro don't agree with him now i'm not i'm
agreeing with both of you
during different depending on what
you're saying and that's how it's
supposed to be brendan always agrees
with you
bro he agrees with you off-screen
sometimes off-screen
yeah yeah maybe
after after this show he'll be like i
kind of agree with what's the always
saying
sorry let's keep it moving here what's
this guy doing what's this big fella
of course this guy's a [ __ ] king of
the sticker i can't even [ __ ] believe
it dude these guys
this is one of our finer fans as well i
will say that that's a pretty cool shirt
actually was that old school super bowl
what's up king in this thing uh brandon
eric uh
daughter and her baby daddy a couple
weeks ago
set her porn
like just random porn that he found on
twitter that's not his hand and so my
question is how should i kill the
[ __ ]
all right
now well um nice i don't know it's just
weird she doesn't want me to press him
but like oh he's got the lingo too you
might have to you know oh you got to say
something that shit's just out of pocket
you feel me yeah uh so let me know what
y'all think and
gang gang buzz buzz he goes in and out
of being mexican that guy he's white and
then mexican and then white and mexican
yeah he's halfway there look he's one
generation two generations it's a wrap
well he's beige soon this guy so let me
get this straight
so his ex sent his current girls
sent his current girl porn like a whole
segment of porn uh his current
girlfriend's uh baby daddy centerpoint
oh wow
randomly and it was it wasn't like of
him it was like some random twitter porn
but he's like remember when we used to
do this you know what i'm saying like i
need content yeah if it was just the
link way different than yo remember when
i used to wax that ass like this yeah do
you know what i mean do you don't have
contacts you don't know remember i used
to go balls deep like this you know like
that well let me tell you something i
feel like that's implied the fact that
well look the fact that this guy didn't
clear it up and wasn't specific makes me
angry
he should have he should have added any
more details he should ask wow i don't i
don't think you want more do you tell it
could have been an errant text it would
have could have been
but you don't want the guy remember you
what do you want to know more well no
i'm saying because what if she responded
she could respond back like what yeah
thumbs up
something's up you don't just say this
[ __ ] this is more than this and then
you've been like oh my god i'm so
embarrassed my bad i sent you whatever
this is like the shock.com you know
we're we're in like this is like the
first few episodes of the first season
it gets way deeper dude yes you know
what i mean we're like we're like oh
okay that's happening and it's like in
[ __ ] season three we're like it was
this the whole
that's what's happening to this guy and
i hope that he knows that you know what
i'm saying like if this first 48 we're
not solving for 48 hours i don't know
what you're saying and i'm thinking
about dope sick is really good but this
guy dude i think you got to put a filter
on it urban them up put a [ __ ] make
it a merv and put that [ __ ] on world
star dude him this guy right here yeah
that's the thing go a little more to the
white or a little more to the yeah
middle yeah he's in the middle it's two
in the middle if you're playing the
middle i'm not surprised that's what
people are sending you pictures of all
the time dude the middle dog
because more far right that dude ain't
sending your girl porno no also yeah
that's true that is true
yeah difficult but also it is
interesting that he does have the
reverse hitler mustache as well so um
what is up with the [ __ ] you guys
your your fans their hair is so scared
of their nostrils it's unbelievable
get away
mr ping lips dude he's a pink lip like
face
bro we got [ __ ] wet ass eric andre
dude somebody's what is going on derek
andre
all right how beige is everybody that's
what it is today man white or black this
guy could be black
puerto rican you can't even hate anyone
yeah i know i know
that's true but those lips i love those
lips bro his name is elon
tayman okay who knows who made it up
[Music]
jesus man when does it end he could even
be transitioning we have no [ __ ] idea
what this is take me back 20 years where
you can yell something out of the window
and be correct
yeah
yeah
it's just like yeah you get it wrong now
[ __ ] you whoever
[ __ ] you oh i'm not that my bad bro [ __ ]
you i'm judeo spanish
yeah stay enemies
title names stay enemies
another way brendan chris
the failed ugly brother of blake griffin
and maybe stevie would be this week nice
anyways guys my name is elaine from
toronto that's not his hand and i need a
quick relationship advice for you guys
so i've been talking to this girl for i
think let's say a year now his voice is
not to hang out so i need some
relationship advice do i keep talking to
her we've been texting almost every day
sometimes three to four times a day
sometimes just once a day and she always
finds an excuse
whether it's been work or just family
stuff do i keep going for it or you know
do i seek attention from other women and
go another route with it so let me know
gang gang buzz not his hand i'll tell
you right now he's got so many jackets
he's got a jacket on all [ __ ] he
definitely has no pants on canada this
is this is he is that's russian what did
he hear the words going off of his legs
yeah he has you could tell just by this
he has no furniture in there yeah
because he's activated he broke into a
place obviously to make this video
he's in the girl's place right now
depending on what we see he might kill
her what do i do sometimes we text all
the time once a day what once a day
sometimes we text all the time once a
day sometimes
we take four
times four yeah yeah
i never hear from her yeah
i probably won't hear from her again
after i kill her tonight i mean her
house
bro will text her one more time then she
died bro there is no [ __ ] way
there is no way this guy let me uh
he doesn't really know how life is huh
you got to stop it might be a catfish
though yeah if she refuses to meet with
him but he said they facetimed it he
said they've i did follow up with this
guy and he said they faced time three or
four times she always cuts
oh bro was it on instagram oh she's
using the [ __ ] the grinch filter or
what she's married that's what's
happening not bro she is not married she
is either a catfish or she does not want
to hang out with this dude do you think
that this guy um here we go
[ __ ] man
[ __ ] you guys it's okay bro it happens
to me all the time man [ __ ] you guys and
[ __ ] you too
all right
um he is um
you gotta not do he's he's not a bad
looking dude he's chilling i mean his
personality we have no idea what he is
he's every little voice he's everything
he's every looking is good yeah and he
can do he could be anything he could be
president he could work uh outdoors
he could work indoors this guy could do
whatever he wants dude underwater above
water this dude is an amphibian this guy
probably has [ __ ] glands in his
elbows
who knows what's going on that's true no
wonder your life's all over the place
you're all over the place you also give
up on homegirl clearly she doesn't want
to meet her and she doesn't want to meet
you
the weirdest part about this video is
like he's right in front of the door
which is hilarious that he's like just
got home have to do this video like dude
sit down first
relax
yeah he did it's awfully snowing he came
here and what is going through the video
he just came from outside you could tell
by his lips and the jacket's all the way
all the way zipped up it's weird bro but
but i like you're a pink lip brother
that's me my lips are always wet bro
gang gang buzz buzz
come on gang gang buzz you can't say
that
that's mine
i got red i got red lips they're always
wet dude gang gang buzz buzz
buzz red lips yeah dude this place has
gone downhill since i left
dude well i'll tell you this this guy
obviously you say something brendan
you forgot to say i mean wait oh finally
100 episodes
bro all right here we go
it's chin's aunt there we go huh dude
those cans are big upside down these
chins are medium calm down rudder big to
me
hey king in the sink fam i need some
relationship advice my wife and i have
been together together
a year and a half now
i'm only a little bit living with the
mother of his kids and he's been for a
very long time
and he's been during her whole entire
relationship and
i'm not okay with it i've never been and
i don't want to go into year two
with this happening how do you guys help
me convince him that he needs to see the
removal
or move out with me
because this cannot keep happening for
the duration of our relationship if he
wants this to work for the best
let me get this straight she i didn't
hear the beginning
so she uh
so she
you ruined it so she
i ruined it so she she's with a guy who
lives with his baby mom yeah right she's
only been dating a year and a half oh
that's too long
she's he's been living with the whole
time and he just doesn't well it might
be for the kids
it's clearly for the kids it's gotta be
for the kids
for a year and a half yeah
the mom lives with them the mom lives
with her boyfriend who's is that and i'm
assuming it's because of the kids but
also a year and a half i didn't know how
old the kids are the kids are like 14
16. again i need more deep i know they
don't give you my main problem with your
fans
if you want us to solve this crime we
need more details it's too many it's too
many uh it's it's too much information
we don't have would you
say your wife have children elsewhere
okay would it be okay if your wife lived
there
hell no
no i started thinking about all the free
time but no way
no way no way no way no way
no but i'm not live there i really would
like it if she was active in her kids
lives okay like and [ __ ] does a lot
of stuff with them i think that's great
but live there like sleep at night there
yeah does he have to sleep can the kids
go to bed and then he comes over yeah
how often does he whip seeing what he's
in the night yeah
my kids go to bed charles um not charles
but who's the guy
uh
um who's the famous country singer
garth brooks oh no i got this um garth
brooks we already got it something
chased something we got it um
uh garth brooks his he goes over to his
house after his kids go to sleep and he
goes back over there when they wake up
that's cool huh in between he lives next
door with his other wife brooks oh wow
savage move so he's next door
kids before they wake up he's in the
he's catching breakfast they leave he's
all broke goes back garth brooks really
yeah
that's cool so he got a wife on the same
land wow but that's so much he has so
much money right you know this is
different yeah the kids don't watch the
show and he just blew his spot up they
know maybe he's gonna have to know maybe
he's chris gaines at the house
oh yeah remember you gotta leave the
guitar here yeah you look like chris
gaines a little bit thank you very much
thank you i accept that chris gaines is
[ __ ] damned
chris gaines also known as garth brooke
yeah guard book
guard broke also known as chen who's
garb yeah that's right what's up with
this one look at this oh he's a magician
she's a magician
this is chris angel yeah it's it's same
guy look at the [ __ ] chin that's the
worst thing ever
boy did that [ __ ] thing oh boy did mary
announced it on saturday live and just
ate [ __ ] honestly he probably made so
many millions of dollars from it but for
him that's a failure you know her eyes
are breathtaking yeah but that's a
filter come on
that ain't real hi king listening my
name is dr a long time
it's more of like a generalization than
actual like a specific
piece of advice but i want to know your
guys's thoughts on long-distance
relationships do you think it's worth it
dating someone in a different town or do
you think it's a waste of time do you
know anyone who's successfully dated
long distance um i live in a super small
town there's not a lot of dating options
here
so i just wondered what you guys's
thoughts were on that thanks
is there any longer you can see through
the other town like she can i mean this
one obviously
has freaking gps vision dude her eyes
are nothing it's amazing but i think
long distance you just applies you're
going to be on the phone all the time if
you like being on the phone
i hate it you like it you call sometimes
you're a caller right i don't mind
calling but all long distances you're
just
texting me just subscribe
account that's basically what a
long-distance relationship is no you're
drowning off on facetime just doing an
only fans account that's your idea of it
but you get to see but you get to see
the person like you get to get away like
if you it depends on how busy and how
full your life is if you're a [ __ ]
single person and you're killing it and
you're having a good time you have a
good profession and you're in pittsburgh
and then somebody you know that doesn't
often happen in pittsburgh and then
somebody you meet somebody in san
francisco and they're [ __ ] killing it
in san francisco doing they're busy
right you're both busy and you get away
for a weekend every two weeks and that
works for your life then great if you
want more than that which you do because
she's a female like let's be honest you
know then it's not going to want more
and i want you to ask that question in
your heart
i want her to ask that question to her
because if she asks that question her
heart should start crying do you need me
it's not enough and the answer is yes
yeah wow how about this just move move
now and then it won't be long distance
if he's worth it
yeah no no i'm saying move before you
even meet somebody go to a better city
that you want to be in yeah and then
meet somebody there this is your life
this is your life i feel bad that a lot
of women and that's obviously tom brady
not doing well since they lost that's
tom brady on meth yeah
i think if somebody lives in a different
town you gotta be able to get over there
and see him sometimes i remember lying i
remember telling people i saw i met this
girl in another town and i never did
meet her i just lied for like two years
and said i was in a relationship that's
really cool i like that oh you cat it
was catfish yeah it was like before that
catfish it was just me just lying to
people about it and it was like uh and i
would make all these valentine's cards
and [ __ ] from her even for you
would you show the other people then
yeah okay at least you're like getting
the credit i mean he's like
yourself
yeah i would it's very very lonely if
you didn't show anybody this the art you
get yeah
look what amy brought me yeah if you do
that it's sad but it's not as sad well
people like when is she coming by and i
would always pretend that she went by on
like they had one bus that would come
from the other county and they come
through and i pretend like she was on
that boss and like
you know what i think you know what you
know what i think it might be you're gay
that's what gay guys do you know
you're gay it's okay to be gay though i
think you're just closeted dude you're
like
from another town
she wrote a valentine's card
look yo that's your handwriting if i was
gay i would know you idiots
don't you think i would have any idea no
no i don't i don't know you just came
out to us
the mind is crazy bro you have to admit
the mind is crazy but it's not gay
the mind ain't gay dude
it's not sometimes you ever think maybe
i'm gay maybe i i'm saying sometimes you
have do you ever stop and think what if
i am gay you've thought about it
if you don't do that then that's gay
yeah because you got to give it some
thought to know you're not that yeah so
if you're like no way you're secretly
gay yeah if you're sitting in your truck
you just blast the heater and you're
like
yeah
that's the case you're well in the
closet under the clothes yeah bro well
sometimes you porn the suggestions
[Laughter]
i have never seen gay porn i've never
seen gay porn that's how they that's
this is how you know guys i'm sure a lot
of men have wondered if they're gay or
not or had a moment where it's like am i
gay i'm stuck in an elevator am i yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah if you a lot of
times doctors will say if i don't use it
already but pornography
if you've ever looked at gay pornography
you're gay and one and had in been
intrigued to really experience more then
you may have you may be
partially gay yeah semi-gay all good
dude
all good or if you're going on a ski
trip with a bunch of buddies in oregon
it's all dudes and you're locked in we
don't know maybe there's chick maybe
there's chicks
there's chase
chicks i know okay
now speaking of gay what up king and
esteem
brendan
uh montez
stevie if he's there
theo he's not in a meeting
crystalia maybe
whoever else
got a king in the sting for you guys
getting swole
getting thick
working out working out okay with your
girl i noticed that uh what's it what
i'm working out what's plugged in behind
him and uh throwing weights and my girls
there is that long enough to start
staring at her ass
start uh fantasizing of what it'd be
like to uh bang her out right there on
the squat rat is this a suicide note so
uh
he's not doing it
why does he only have a hat on i know
cause that's how they're doing it that's
kids these days um what what was your
girlfriend
what was his question
working out with your girl yeah working
out with your girl and that's his girl
oh that's long neck they look very
similar right along that pop one out he
got a kid no yeah can i have a long neck
huh kid i have a long neck yeah it was
born like six pounds 700 inches
they didn't even do it by feet yeah it
was just like doctors like we don't do
it by feet when it's like this he's just
pulling it out of there like one of
those like magicians handkerchiefs
whatever
uh ostrich yeah just this guy seems like
definitely kind of uh
oh wow wow there's long
you know that guy before the drugs yeah
that's his cousin we actually
have a we have we are second or third no
no get the [ __ ] out of here but it
explains a lot but are you serious yeah
no stop it
is this like your fake girlfriend
no she's real there she goes
yeah that bus comes over here
i see her every tuesday yeah that's neck
and that's before what prom or something
or maybe ged well let's hope so ged
uh but no i think that guy i i sometimes
i'll say this if i see a man at the gym
and his girlfriend's there
sometimes i get envious
because that guy has a girl with them
maybe she's cute maybe she also lifts
weights
but i if i used to go to the gym with my
girlfriend and she came over and i gave
me a kiss or something or [ __ ] hugged
me i would [ __ ] just squirm really
inside of myself so what do you think
about because i think i wanted to be
single i wanted to be like i'm doing my
own thing and then she comes over and
she's like is everything okay i can help
you you know you need a spot yeah he's
like i'm fine
you [ __ ] it up interesting i'm in the
car with the heater
oh wait that's interesting because it's
you're saying you want both you're
saying you ride the complete i like the
gym time solo it's your getaway you know
i'm saying you don't have to do
everything together it's a little weird
you don't have to do everything but now
if you were gay it'd be pretty dope to
have a guy good spot oh yeah that would
be really cool yeah same you got a gay
buddy that spotted y'all
yeah a lot of guys who are heterosexual
say that a lot so
no i think i i don't have i don't have
anything against that working out with
your girl why not you don't have to do
everything with them that's what i'm
saying but but but but no but i'm saying
it's a separate time yeah no i
understand but you could do things other
other things separately
right like
but you're right that's the only thing
no but like i don't know like also she's
getting fit you're getting fit [ __ ] it
sure but what i don't like is the couple
that's there the one who's over there
cutting up the cutlet or something and
she they're feeding them and they're
just [ __ ] a couple of like that and
her tits are just hard as hell you know
yeah that's a lot yeah that's too much
that yeah that's but nobody wants to be
that shredded injector what about would
you let your girl have like a like big
buff like trainer
she she goes to him she goes to him
three times a week but it's at his house
bro the trainer is the first dude who's
gonna bang your i know i know no you
don't understand my thought process
100 you don't understand my thought
process on that you want to get bank
down no i don't you don't understand
dude if you wanted something i don't
need to say all the stuff sales and you
didn't mean to it's okay i don't find it
this is why yeah no it's fine i didn't
say basically
dude but it's fine
go ahead man i'm just you would like to
ask him brendan it's not gonna happen
four times a week and this dude just a
dime piece how about asking your [ __ ]
coins do this do it seven times a week
oh
hope so dude i bet it doesn't happen and
if it does
we deal with it
yeah man
we deal with it confidence we deal with
it dude
i've got so much other [ __ ] going on in
my brain
i'll deal with it you understand oh wow
you you do it but she's not gonna crack
if she does
your boy's still alive and we'll deal
with it wow
and i need it there you go trainers hit
him up in the dms hit my girl up in the
d let's see this shit's got to go though
this morning i'm going to be the trainer
with your girl there's your girl
yeah
there you go middle finger in the
[ __ ]
i like to hear if a guy hit on her i
like to hear look come on let me know
let me know dude let me know where were
you the [ __ ] market some guy said
something yeah let me know dude yeah
yeah why do you sell like smell like
black pickle
what market were you at huh
who's this guy is this a king of the
sting thing or another podcast we're
about to watch yeah
of course with the beard bro
you guys know him
oh no i did i did a show with this guy
one time he's a comedian what's going on
everybody my name is boxy beats from los
angeles california this is my friend
loopy loopy loopy loopy loopy
[Music]
looping version
before you answer check this out
the oh just getting some fire the
[ __ ] scent the the face he made after
the first loopy yeah it was the most
insecure face in the world now this one
i want to point he said the first which
was only a one week brenden by the way
my friend loopy
loopy loopy right there oh so insecure
come on man
be a man about it what happened he's
insecure right there you can see by his
head but he's looping before you make
fun of me yeah exactly but is i
basically going to see what he's got
that is brendan all right let's see what
he's got
you're having a little extra sip that's
brenda that's eggnog that's so difficult
first
i mean the lights in the back you know
fire
burden falls for any beat in the
beginning though that's he's the first
dude to [ __ ] drop like yeah i'll go
to the dance floor with this king and
the stink king and the stink king in the
sting king he's actually got a good
voice
that's amazing
and brennan just stole a sandwich
and a book but he gets rid of the book
immediately for 100
this guy is very cool this guy is cool
oh he drink that's so dick to drink
[Music]
but this is nature
that was fire that was really cool that
was good i expected it to go further did
you oh no actually i thought it would do
that you guys are lying no no i thought
you made a little more to it i didn't
know i like the that's your that's one
of his problems though
you don't expect greatness but that's
but i'm not saying that that wasn't
great or it was great i expected it to
be met your standards
yeah when i see a guy like that those
are my standards yeah okay no i'm not
trying to be shitty but he's i don't
know who he is he's just a guy who
submitted something usually people who
submit are not that amazing
william been on kingston
i'm just saying dude submit submitting
has never been amazing you saw a little
browse last week
fire but i don't know him from
submitting i know him from being fired
little brown right yeah that [ __ ] is
fire when i know somebody if it's from
mission
ambulance
i'll shake my dick to it interesting i
will snap my dick to that yeah we used
to live by uh
er
so we'd always hear them [ __ ] coming
in dude guessing what happened
fire fire yeah yeah
yeah we didn't have that much gunshots
but it's mostly fire
um
burns burns from chemicals
chemical burn animal attacks domestic
disputes that's a lot of that your girl
never visited yeah
[Laughter]
no she's staying home there's a lot of
violence
uh thanks for the beat man i i think i
just thought it was gonna escalate me
too yeah i think if he had like a cool
vocalist he could do like the the beat
for him and then someone else yeah that
was dope though
yeah appreciate it he's cool
yo what up cats gang wow i got a king in
her stinging thumb on the mic coming
from lower slower delaware the lsd
all right here it is
so
what the [ __ ] dead animals on the wall
okay hanging up
each one got a story you know
we got my first
great camerawork first buck there's a
wall
and
how hard is that to hunt it's not hard
because it was it could have been in the
city or it could have been this dude he
could have shot it in the [ __ ] jungle
or wherever animals are and then [ __ ]
brought it back
snipped the antlers off and put it on
there and then put his hat on it which
is really [ __ ] up if you think about
it to take what the animal has put it on
your wall and then put one of your
things on top of your head over the
animals disrespectful that's disrespect
on top of disrespect so what this guy's
doing is not good but he also went a lot
of different animals yeah and it was all
tiny little deer yeah it's all the same
animals yeah i know and there was a
squirrel's head and i think there was a
set of dalmatian ears on there
that's definitely some dicey choices but
i yeah i think i agree with you on that
i say sting that because
if you do get an animal yeah you should
or put the animal's thing on your head
like
out of respect right
that's respect yeah but yeah i think to
hang a bunch of stuff on it probably
yeah or if you saw the animal and had
that on and it's just too easy to hunt
here's my rule with hanging animals on
the wall it should only be able to kill
you like you have a giant bear on there
a [ __ ] dope
yeah a big-ass rhinoceros somebody with
a crocodile yeah yeah a method with a
knife
yeah you know what i mean
but like just the hood yeah yeah yeah
with the head and um but yeah it's tough
you can't eat the animal and wear the
antlers that's boss but like you know
but also don't put like
you know animals that can't hurt you on
the wall also if you have a place like
that not no knock i know [ __ ] but like
don't you don't need antlers on the wall
those curtains were [ __ ] nine dollars
you know what i mean like
yeah but i think now we'll i will say
this showing that you've haunt you've
been out there and got something good
and [ __ ]
a lot of chicks dig it um no no and then
you go you want some milk sausage
that's his movie
and then you just write elk on your own
dick and come back in the room
that's a [ __ ] move right
you didn't think about that yeah
you should have brought your brain come
on bro three letters wouldn't fit on
your dick
that ain't your joke it's his
that ain't fair you tell a joke
i even went like this
that's insane
i've always said if you're gonna kill an
animal i think it should be hand to hand
combat you go out there with a knife and
that's how you hunt the animal that's
the way i really that's the way i think
it's that's where you're at
you go out there and you hunt it
hand-to-hand man you don't be having
those
ak-47s or
the luxury of your head
i don't know man i use grenades no
no no i don't know i don't i don't know
how i feel about that i'm not a hunter
no no one's a hunter here no well theo
is i've thrown a grenade before
have you yeah i've thrown a grenade
where what if he's just like at home
somebody had a grenade and i threw it
who the [ __ ] had a grenade in louisiana
tell you who a senior citizen
oh he's a war veteran wow what do you
think about this buckaroo and he had a
[ __ ] hot weight on him and dude i'll
tell you when he threw it actually
everybody was at a ball game and uh
that's when he first showed it to
everybody and then he threw it at like a
livestock area it was like show-and-tell
some animals died yeah god damn and when
was this this was in 1995.
whoa so you were young as [ __ ] you were
14. [ __ ] grenade baby wow and i'll
tell you this as soon as he threw that
bit he took his shirt off too to throw
that [ __ ] and you gotta well i would
and did you throw one two or no huh no
you did not so you saw someone throw a
grenade so i lied i yell out when you no
no that's okay though that's not really
a lie i mean but i mean i was right
there dude i could have um there's a lot
of people i did shake his hand after
that works
you know that grenade was for vietnam
yeah that's exactly what happened well
it was one of the ones not even with the
drawings on the side of it where they
draw the cool parts real [ __ ] it was
like oh that was like a smooth one like
one that looks like the lemon at the
euro
they call that a cherry grenade i think
oh you don't say i think after that just
own it i made that up okay well i don't
like anything that's going on right now
with this might be a cherry it's a
cherry grenade yeah it's a red cheddar
grenade you [ __ ] well that just made
me want
that made me hungry
you want to get a grenade huh let's see
one more thing here what happened here
nick uh this was just a quick cats in
the wild someone was at the gym and saw
eric getting his steps in at planet
fitness
eric's gonna be so big i know
oh that's all right
that's a hundred percent eric that's
good oh that's awesome
that's how eric walks right there that's
how eric rocks from his bedroom to go
play video games
that is eric isn't it
unbelievable dude
that's great
look at the two dudes behind that next
to him laughing at him
the other clown
that's great it's my uh
yeah
yeah that's exactly why it's catchment i
like what he was doing with his hands
that was good and we didn't have a topic
for this but i'm i'm sure you saw this
theo i'm sure people sent it to you some
some monkeys escaped just like in
louisiana yep
i got a lot of traffic a lot of internet
traffic on that
well definitely a truck crash and the
monkeys just jumped out 100 monkeys
escaped and they got them all back i
guess except for four
some dude sent me a video said him and
his friends were going looking for
they're just drunk at night going to
look for them
pretty well those four monkeys are going
to start a business
and they're out there with hats on and
[ __ ] yeah they're all posing for nfts
right now
they're bored they're making birch
should we do one more king of steam
let's just do it man it's hot in here eh
is it hot in here
what up brendan chinchilla
that other guy
reaching out to you from that lockdown
capital melbourne australia oh wow uh
going bank accounts ben simmons
oh sometimes i just want to grab a
burger without getting questioned yeah
joint bank no
gain buzzing no no joint background no
no no no no your money's your money
get yours whoa whoa guys i know how i
know how hot i came in with that and i
meant it put your money where your wife
is do bet on your lady huh well that's
not betting on your lady though that's
just like being being weird it's like
just have two bank accounts right and do
you give her money every month no well
she has her own yeah who gives a [ __ ]
she has a credit card card yeah yeah and
then also yeah what do i know i don't
even have a ladies you've been single
so you just give her a stack of money
like it's [ __ ] nice
yeah yeah exactly i need this much no
you just yeah give her three inches of
money i mean some sometimes the the
women work too and they get their own
money [ __ ] yeah yeah bro i don't know
if you know but times are different now
they can get jobs
i know yeah no i bet but for me that
that's what you can tell yeah yeah
plus your credit card extra work yeah
yeah you don't need to do it yeah
this guy's clearly struggling with it
that's my family family portrait
it's like actually a cute drawing
i can't see from right here
that's all we got that's it nicki
that was an hour right
oh yeah yeah yeah they turned the heat
on in this [ __ ] i like the heat i love
i love it yeah i love it warm it's too
hot i love it warm but you know theo you
look good with that around your head
like that really yeah you do that's
where the rat king do you really look
good is that what what's that right why
is that right
kingpin the rat king oh they're
wrestling no from teenage mutant ninja
turtles oh is it from that he's the dude
it's identical
in your way you gave him the nightmare
oh you ran with it oh it's very good
people sent it and they mailed it in too
people mailed him oh there you go that's
steel
the rack
dude the uh i started wearing those
strips on my nose at night to breathe
better do you guys ever do that yes
never how nice is it honestly it's
fantastic really yeah and just that
little strip opens up there it's
incredible it's like going on vacation
wow i need to get some then and how
about this makes every show better your
wife's better all of a sudden yeah yeah
yeah your [ __ ] kid is not even as bad
as he was yeah and this is coming from a
guy without a kid or a wife i know
somebody i'll tell you
but i tell you
you get one of those and then you take
them off in the morning that's just like
coming home from the vacation that sucks
yeah it starts to take it off in the
morning the rest of the day you know
once you swear the whole day
you'd be an [ __ ] you'd be an [ __ ]
yeah i used to have a guy that would
come sometimes to our apartment and uh
kind of do like polish up the furniture
stuff because my old roommate had a lot
of special like antique wooden furniture
and this guy always wore his when he
came in it was wow very weird it's
distracting but the the ones if you get
the generic ones this the the sticky
isn't as strong and it doesn't get stuck
on your nose yeah it's not good but even
honestly sometimes when it flaps up
it still keeps this one open and you're
good like i'll let my [ __ ] flap up and
i'll just be like i'm not going to fix
it i'm still going to sleep yeah yeah
wow yeah
dude it is hit one you should shut up
you ever tried two
i got a big number a rebel really i have
a big name oh he needs three you try two
try three yeah try start right here
[Laughter]
that's hilarious chris where are you on
tour chrissy
i'm gonna do brea and i'm gonna do
irvine that's what i'm gonna do
crystallia and friends we got a february
one of february and one coming up also
and i think april which is way too far
but you know i don't know when this is
coming out
and i am by the time this comes out i
will be in
i'm in atlanta tonight i'm in atlanta at
the punch line i'm in atlanta and that
is february 3rd through the 5th and then
sacramento is february 24th through the
26th
but atlanta is tonight friday saturday
and sacramento is february 24th through
the 26th get your song
gang baby and i'll be over at uh florida
oh you're doing shows i know you're
doing shows theater oh jacksonville yeah
saint yes yes i am dinner dude i got
some
st petersburg
february 3rd
uh february 4th we got temp improv i
might add a late show there so you could
check that out um
it's awesome i love tampa orlando is
february 5th orlando uh yeah and you can
get those at theovon.com tour and then
rockford illinois february 25th and
chicago uh theater february 27th 6th
ooh wilton nice 26. yeah
so come on and show some love man and um
chris thanks for coming in and being a
part of our yeah man it's fun with
things today i i really enjoy myself
it's good to be back thank you guys for
your support kings and the sting that's
it baby thank you guys
love ya
[Music]
[Applause]
theo said that he was on his way but ran
out of gas
stevie weeby used to wrestle down at
parkway
[Music]
what up chin what up nick stevie weeby
eric griffin just walked in and got it
lit you can't forget about brendan he
still need everything dick dick still
got the bees and the trap trapping still
the king and the sting so quit asking if
you know then you know it's a cat's
thing ball and chain hair swang like the
rat can king and the stink
back with the crew we got stevie weeby
eric griffin brendan do2 yeah you know
how we do it so just tune in for the
laughs theo said that he was on his way
but ran out of gas
[Music]
[Applause]
king and the sting